lori lightfoot mayor of chicago
the one thing i kind of respect about
lori lightfoot is
her just absolute brazen cynicism
she doesn't try she doesn't really try
to gladhand she just
she's just a pure power corrupt machine
politician
and there's something you've got to give
a grudging respect to that so lori
lightfoot
is in big trouble because crime is
spiking throughout chicago that place is
like fallujah right now
crime is way way up she's she's lying
and pretending that it's down year over
year but you've seen huge spikes
you know up in crime in shootings and in
murders
and lori lightfoot says the only reason
people are complaining about this
is because she's a black woman
there have been questions raised about
your your temperament and
your reaction to criticism tribune
editorial use the term
irascible how much of this do you think
might have to do with the fact that
you're a woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it look at my predecessors
um did did people say that rich daley um
held you know a t sessions
uh with people that he didn't disagree
on uh ron emanuel
was a polite um guy who was a uniter
no women and people of color are always
held to a different standard
i understand that i've known that my
whole life
that's it she's such a victim the mayor
of chicago she's such a victim
you know so she can't succeed
she can't become um the mayor of a major
american city no because of the racism
amazing amazing how that the racism
didn't prevent her from rising to a very
high political position
but it is causing her to be criticized
has nothing to do with the bullets
and the deaths and the the
riots that took place and the looting
and the arson
and the murders no no it's just because
she's a black woman right
by the way if you dare if you dare
criticize
that kind of line of argument oh man the
establishment is going to come after you
especially
if you are a white person especially if
you're
a white dude oh that's really bad i'm
glad you like that clip we've got a
whole episode it's called
unknown knowns check it out right here
on youtube you can get it also on apple
podcast spotify all those different
places
you can also buy my book the national
bestseller speechless controlling words
controlling minds thank you so much to
everyone who
has ordered that book already really
appreciate all of you if you haven't
gotten it yet go
get it see you next time
[Music]
you